every time you would you would do that  walk he would play the scene slightly  differently it felt  it felt yeah I'm sure there was lots of  I think he was giving just lots of  options he's also when in full  y mode if you will he's incredibly fluid  and flowing and you never quite know  where he's gonna go next which is  quite frightening to be honest with you  as an actor of Amber's Draco as well you  never quite know what he's gonna yeah  Gonna Do Well Done Draco  well done  [Music]  and then he and then he hugged you  that's when that's when the hug happened  yeah that was um I could feel him  stopping me in the walk and when he puts  his hand up he generally  stop and then he didn't know he was  going to do that no idea in my head I'm  going what is he doing and then the  other arm comes out and I'm like he  doesn't want to hug me does he he's like  he's gonna hug me here it comes  and it wasn't yeah incredibly awkward  um but also she